after years of complacency ignorance and
apathy it seems that many americans are
finally waking up to the sexual
indoctrination of our children which is
happening everywhere in schools
hollywood media academia corporate
america i mean everywhere
there was last year kind of an awakening
about critical race theory
decades after it already infiltrated the
school system unfortunately but there
was an awakening and awakening and now
it seems finally that it is gender
theory's turn
just as happened last year with critical
race theory
now we're seeing seemingly every day
new revelations exposing just how
perverse and pervasive this stuff is so
over the last 24 hours um there was uh
first of all this posted by libs of tick
tock on twitter it says
a preschool corporation with branches
across america has an extensive lgbtq
curriculum including activities to
explore gender and sexuality this
activity says to switch caps on a marker
to show what you are inside doesn't
always reflect what you are on the
outside
very scientific stuff and then there's a
prompt
for a discussion on all the terms
they're teaching preschoolers about
gender fluidity and non-binary
they learn about gender stereotypes
including that boys can wear dresses and
you should never assume someone's gender
they're teaching preschoolers to become
activists for the lgbtq plus community
they advise teachers to confuse
preschoolers with dolls to show that you
can't make assumptions about gender this
again is for preschoolers in 40 states
but then there's this from the wisconsin
spotlight it says parents
are not entitled to know their kids
gender identity according to a recent
woke training session in the eau claire
area school district empower wisconsin
has obtained a copy of a training slide
from last friday's staff development
session the 2021-2022 equity session on
safe spaces
reminds teachers that parents are not
entitled to know their kids
identities not entitled to let me
pause and back up there a second
parents are not entitled to know
their kids identities
that knowledge must be earned
teachers are often straddling this
complex situation
in uh ecasd our priority is supporting
the students
um teachers were encouraged to talk
amongst yourselves
and then it goes on um
well first of all just pausing here
parents aren't entitled to know
this intimate information about their
own children teachers are entitled to
know it parents have to earn the
knowledge
parents must prove themselves worthy
and they do that by demonstrating their
fealty to left-wing ideology that's how
you know if uh if it if you're it's a
safe space or not right that's how you
know if uh a child is going to be in a
safe environment is if the
parent is a leftist and so before they
can
know this information about their child
they have to first prove that they're
leftist only then can they be entrusted
with the secret knowledge about their
own children but the article has more it
says a district court in 2022 issued a
partial injunction against madison
metropolitan school district's policy
allowing children of any age to
transition to a different identity at
school without parental consent the full
case is now before the wisconsin
wisconsin supreme court the wisconsin
institute for law and liberty and the
alliance defending freedom filed a
lawsuit on behalf of a group of parents
challenging the gender identity policy
that violates the rights of parents to
make important health care decisions on
their children's behalf
this is what the policy that they're
suing about states
these are the provisions children of any
age can transition to a different gender
identity at school by changing their
name and pronouns without parental
notice or consent of any age so
five-year-olds can do this
district employees are prohibited from
notifying parents without the child's
consent
that their child has or wants to change
gender identity at school or that their
child may be dealing with gender
dysphoria
so
essential information about your child's
mental health will not be shared with
the parents unless the child
has the maturity to realize that oh my
parents should know about my mental
health
district employees are even
instructed to deceive parents by using a
child's legal name and pronouns with
family
while using the different name and
pronoun
adopted by the child in the school
setting
somehow um though
these two things are not the most
shocking or repulsive news to come out
of the grooming world this week i think
that title belongs to this as reported
by the post-millennial it says a
virtual summer camp aimed at people of
all ages in rural rural appalachia
has been revealed to have taught people
including children about masturbation
gender diversity self-managed abortions
and more over the summer of 2021.
the so-called sexy summer camp put on by
sexy sex ed was held in july and august
of last year on tuesdays and thursdays
sexy sex ed puts on workshops that they
just where they discuss
um
that they say rather quote compels
teenagers and people of all ages to
openly discuss personal and political
consent
sexual safety and anatomy using visual
and performance art open dialogue and
popular education methods
sexy sex ed fills a vital gap in the
reproductive education as a creative
cultural healing solution in rural
appalachia
now
journalist christopher rouffeau has
pulled some of the screenshots from this
program
including images
of the women who are running this
pedophile workshop
you can see the images there he reports
these women are running a sexy summer
camp for children of rural kentucky with
lessons on sex liberation gender
exploration bdsm being a sex worker
self-managed abortions and sexual
activity while using listed and illicit
drugs
the founder is a woman named tanya
turner
and she identifies herself as a femme
fat queer magical pleasure worker
educator and artist
she also self-identifies as a witch
and i have no problem with that
self-identification one of her grooming
comrades is caitlyn cummings
real name as far as i can tell and she
is a radical queer mountain woman is how
she calls herself and there's kirsten
utten who's a young fat differently
abled community organizer
now interestingly enough when you look
at the pictures of these women
they all look like versions of each
other okay looking at their profiles
it's like looking at one of those faces
of meth progressions
except that the only difference is that
meth addicts tend to be skinny
so we don't have time to dissect this
aspect of the issue but there does
appear to be something about the pervert
groomer left
that makes everyone look the same i mean
they're indistinguishable
um it's as if in their descent into
degeneracy they shed every unique and
appealing characteristic about
themselves turning into a sex-crazed yet
somehow also sexless drone
and you also notice how all of these
women list their fatness
which first of all we can see your
picture you don't need to tell us
second but they they list it like it's a
resume booster
along with their various sexual and
gender identities and so forth
and that's partly because this has
become a substitute for a personality
you know among empty broken people
rather than having a personality they
have labels but it's also because
their membership in various victim
groups is their literal get out of jail
free card allowing them to they hope
get away with being sexual deviants who
prey upon children
um speaking of which one of these
deviants the leader the head witch um
tanya the wicked witch of
petoville
appeared in an instructional video that
that uh
as far as i know is part of this camp
where or at least she's talking about
her own views on things and um she
appears in this video talking about the
wonders of masturbation for children of
all ages
you know like get down with yourself
explore your own body masturbation is
really healthy and i recommend it to
people of all ages
all ages as soon as my nephews could
talk they were doing that that's what
they were doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt tea you can touch your nose but my
sister's not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right but
it feels good right we have to learn
ways to talk to young people about this
so that they know how to explore their
body consensually so that it's not in
public right we don't want people
exploring their bodies in public that's
not consensual
but exploring your body at any age
grandmas grandpas all of us i don't know
why i put my earpiece in to hear that
now before we we analyze what we just
heard there um you should know that this
freak has worked in the school systems
which will not be a surprise to you
where she admits that uh though her job
was not to teach sex ed she always found
a way anyway listen
the last couple years i've worked with
the school systems
and my job definitely was not to teach
sex ed but i
explored
constantly and tried to figure out ways
that i could work this in somehow like
i'm in the school systems now i have an
end surely i can figure this out
so now the disturbing thing is is that
we know that sex ed for her um well one
of the disturbing things is if i can
point to just one but uh it does not
mean here's where babies come from it
means talking to kindergartners about
masturbation and and note how she claims
that people of all ages masturbate um
everyone does it it's normal she says
even toddlers do it now that's not true
of course but
if it was true
if it was something that everyone just
intuitively did at every age
then why do you need to tell people all
the time that they should masturbate
i mean leaving aside how creepy and
gross that is and the fact that this
woman should be in jail
i'm saying even by her own twisted freak
logic
why would you need to teach something to
people if you say
they all do it all the time anyway
well the answer is that she simply
enjoys talking to people especially kids
it seems about her sexual habits and her
fantasies
now if she was an old man walking up to
a kid at the bus stop and asking the
child if he masturbates we would label
him a sex predator and we would throw
him in prison
should the response be any different
here of course not
but though this woman has run into
criticism only from people on the right
of course because the left fully
endorses all of this though she's been
criticized and now the people involved
in sexy summer camp are trying to scrub
all evidence of it from the internet uh
putting taking the website down and
everything it's too late though
in spite of criticism she's not gonna be
arrested they will not face any
repercussions aside from angry comments
from one side of the political aisle
which which they can they can write off
and dismiss is simply uh bigotry
and that's because this is not an
anomaly this is not some sort of extreme
outlier
this sort of thing is happening
everywhere it's part of an agenda it's
part of a conspiracy
one that now hopefully finally
we're waking up too
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated